banner dans le ghetto rien n'a pas de
leurs règles vos propos sont trop raide
moi je viens de nanterre et j'ai
d'autres rêves
[Musique]
je pense que vraiment si j'avais pas
fait son cours je n'aurai pas découvert
vraiment de quoi je suis capable
[Musique]
le fait que ce soit des concours
accessible pour nous les jeunes je pense
que c'est quelque chose de très
important parce que si on regarde bien
les politiciens les avocats quasiment
toutes les personnes qui gèrent ce monde
là sont des personnes qui savent bien
parler je dis pas que j'ai envie d'être
une perceuse qui veut non loin de là
mais je pense qu'on a beaucoup on a
beaucoup à gagner de s'exprimer en
public
[Musique]
et
j'ai jamais été quelqu'un de camp jeudi
très loquace très bavard quelqu'un de
très très turbulent non plus j'ai
toujours été calme discret au début
j'étais grave timide parce que je voyais
qu'ils les intervenants à l'atelier
débat il vraiment ils étaient forts à
travers à travers leurs écrits dans le
charisme qu'ils avaient c'était vraiment
très très très très fort
[Musique]
damman avance à jamais je me serais dit
que je vais prendre la parole devant
devant des avocats devant des
personnalités très importante
j'ai eu la chance quand même de
rencontrer lilian thuram lilian thuram
olivier nakache est ce une bela tarr qui
l'agacent toutes ces personnes là
j'avais l'habitude de les voir à la télé
dans des interviews sur les bons sur des
terrains foot imminente sur amenant
parce que je suis quand même j'aide mes
mégots être je m'attendais vraiment pas
à prendre la parole devant cesser ces
personnes-là quoi si je peux toucher que
certaines personnalités je pense que
voilà quoi grâce à ces genres du
concours on peut toucher le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça m'a permis de me rendre compte que
des fois on se met des barrières nous
mêmes on pense qu'on pense qu'on n'est
pas capable pense qu'on va pas y arriver
ce sont des barrières qu'on se fixe nous
mêmes mais vraiment si on s'écoute pas
si on va au bout de fond si on va au
bout de mon rêve si on voit vraiment si
vraiment on prend le courage et c'est ce
qui est vraiment c'est ce concours la
cesci moi ce qui m'a montré c'est que
tout est possible et qu'on n'est pas on
n'est pas condamné à l'échec